العديد من قاده العالم والشخصيات المرموقه
توجهوا الى الجزيره الاندونيسيه بالي في
الفتره الماضيه لحضور خدمه مجموعه ال 20
لتوقظ هذه القمه جزيره بالي من سبات طويل
سببه وباكرون وتسلط الضوء على قطاع
السياحه للوجه الاستوائيه فسياحه تعد
المصدر الرئيسي للدخل في الجزيره التي
تشتهر بشواطئها الاستوائيه وحقول الارز
المرتده على المدرجات الى جانب المعابد
لكن هذا القطاع شهد انتكاسه كبيره العمل
الماضي فمن سته ملايين سائح قبل الوباء
انخفض عدد السياح الاجانب في جزيره
الساحره الى الضفدع عشرات فقط في 20 21
وفي طاري مساعيها لاحياء قطاع السياحي
اطلق اطبالي برنامج تاشيره للعاملين عن
بعد تحت اسم تاشيره المنزل الثاني من
القرر ان تدخل حيزه في ديسمبر كما اعلنت
شركه اير بي ام بي مؤخرا انها دخلت معها
في الشراكه لاستقطاب العاملين عن بعد وحتى
مع كبح فايروس كورونا فمن المرجح ان
يستغرق تعافي القطاع السياحي في هذه
الجزيره بعد الوقت
[موسيقى]
اظهرت الكثير من الافلام السينمائيه
الطبيعه الساحره لجزيره بالي لكن ما سر
جماليه هذه الجزيره هناك في المحيط الهندي
تظهر جزيره الساحره باليه التي لقبت بجنه
الارض متمتعه بالعديد من معالم السياحه
ومظاهر الطبيعه الخلابه من شواطئ مدهشه
وبحيرات وشلالات تتدفق منها الحياه
التلال البركانيه الكثيره جعلت من بالي
ارضا خصبه بامتياز هذه الخصوبه مع الامطار
التي تستمر لاشهر جعلت من المكان ارضا
مناسبه لزراعه الارز المميزه في المنطقه
جعلها مقصدا للسياحه
فهناك يمكن ان يعيش الانسان اياما مع
طبيعه الساحره بعيدا عن صاحب المدن الكبرى
وتلوث مناخها
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اجواء جزيره بالي الساحره ونذهب
الى منفذت العربيه ناديه بلبيسي ناديه عم
كنا شايفين صور لحسناء بالي انا مش شايفه
غير حسناء واحده اسمها ناديه بالبيسي
ههه
خجلتيني هالقد يا نادين مش معقول يعني انت
عارفه هذا كلام قليل بحقك يعني صباحك احلى
ناديه
ههه
تسلمون بس عن جد يعني كانت رحله شاقه لانه
الفرق الساعات كان كثير كبير بيننا وبين
دبي طبعا بتغطيه القمه لكن نهايه هذه
الرحله عن جد نهايتها مسك مع صباح العربيه
لانه نستطيع ان ننقل صوره للمشاهد عن جمال
هذه الجزيره يعني ربما هي من اشهر الجزر
الاندونيسيه بنعرف رسومات
لكن بالي هي بالفعل جزيره تقدم كل ما
تريدونه يعني بمعنى الشواطئ الجميله
الرمال
التاريخ الثقافه هناك الاف من المعابد
طبعا انا تقريبا هندوسيه 85% من الهندوس
نار كل المعهد لكل الاله هذه الهندسيه
كثيره نرى ايضا زراعه كما ذكر الارز على
مدرجات قديمه استخدام الري- يعني نظام زي
قديم في همم السقي الى اخره ايضا هناك
الجبال البركانيه هناك يعني الراحه
النفسيه في الواقع ممكن ان يجلس الشخص
بدون ان يعمل اي شيء فقط ان ينتقل من مكان
الى مكان هناك محميات طبيعيه زرنا على
فكره قبل ما تسالين السؤال الثاني زورنا
لغابات استوائيه فيها كل البخور والتوابل
يعني مثلا اشجار القرفه هذا القلم راح
اجيب لكم منه على فكره ذكروني مصنوعه من
عيدان القرفه ونرى اشجار القرفه يعني
الشجره ضخمه همم جوزه الطيب همم كل انواع
عملنا كمان جوله في مزارع القهوه مشهوره
جدا في هذه الجزيره بالفعل ساحره بكل معنى
الكلمه ويا ريت كل فريق صباح العربيه
وطبعا
وسهام وسهام وكل اللي بيشتغلوا يجوا معنا
ويشوفوا الحقيقه
الجزر الاندونيسيه لكن بالي بالتحديد تلقب
الجنه الاستوائيه ما الذي ميزها حتى تلقب
بهذا اللقب
كل ما نتحدث عن الشواطئ طبعا هي على
المحيط الهندي الشواطئ عاده احيانا في بعض
الجزر لا تستطيعين استخدام الشواطئ لانه
في شواطئ صخريه لكن شواطئها ناعمه وممتده
فيها خصوصيه وفيها جماليه روحانيه يعني
بتحسي براحه بالفعل راحه نفسيه عادها عن
ذلك التاريخ والثقافه يعني نتحدث عن معابد
وعن ديانات المعابد بنيت بالقرن الثالث
عشر همم نتحدث عن الاوروبيين الذين استوطن
هنا طبعا كانت مستعمره وهولنديه فيها
تاثير وفيها همم يعني اثار لكل الحضارات
التي اتت هنا من اسيا ومن الشرطه ومن
اوروبا الجديديه او هنا في بالي طبعا ما
تحدث عنه من غابات الاستوائيه سؤالين لك
يعني على الصعيد شخصي دائما بيروحوا
الهنيمونه على بالي حسيتي انه هي فعلا
وجهها للحب هيك للاختلاء بين الاحبه هذا
اولا ثاني يعني صورك مع القرد اوصفي لنا
الشعور وكيف كانت تجربه
يعني مش عارفه
ليه ههه
[ضحك]
يا نادين ما فيها رومانسيه بالمره ههه لكن
بالفعل هي وجهها وجهها لكل الاشخاص اللي
عملها دعايه اكيد لانها بتستاهل الفلوس
المتزوجين شهر العسل همم حتى الاشخاص اللي
بدهم يدوروا بس عن الراحه النفسيه ممكن
انه يجوا على بالي بس بالفعل يعني وجهها
بامتياز انا بعملها همم يعني الكومانديشن
توزيع بالنسبه للرود طبعا
هذه محميه على فكره فيها 1500 تبع قرد
تقريبا
وهما فرندلي يعني في غايه طبعا بيقول لك
هلا في ناس بخافوا كثير منهم انا بحب
الحيوانات بشكل عام كل انواع الحيوانات